SIERRA: In 2020 five tech giants - Apple,
Amazon, Google, Microsoft, and Facebook, had
a combined revenue of more than $1.2 trillion.
It makes sense though right - like, I for
one spent a lot of time on my computer that
year.
But many were outraged to learn how little
they had paid in taxes.
This highlights a story that has been unfolding
for decades.
As silicon valley moved fast and broke things,
they also got really good at finding ways
to pay the lowest tax possible - which sometimes
is no tax.
Many of them moved to countries with lower
tax rates resulting in a race to the bottom
- countries competing with each other to offer
lower and lower rates.
The result?
Hundreds of billions in lost tax revenue around
the world.
Large corporations always seem to be two steps
ahead in the tax game.
But there may be a surprising change in store
- an international proposal to charge companies
the same tax rate, no matter where they go.
I’m Gabrielle Sierra and this is Why It
Matters, today, a global minimum tax - the
solution that could change it all, and the
long road ahead.
SIERRA: Can you tell me about this new idea
called global minimum tax?
What is it?
How does it work?
OEI: Generally, a global minimum tax is exactly
what it says.
SIERRA: This is Shuyi Oei.
She is a professor at Boston College Law School
and teaches students all about the wide world
of tax law.
OEI: It's a minimum tax on corporations.
And countries can tax more, but if they tax
less, then things happen.
RUBIN: For several years now, the US and more
than 100 other countries have been talking
to try to find a way to have a more coordinated
corporate income tax system around the world.
SIERRA: And this is Richard Rubin.
He’s the US tax policy reporter for the
Wall Street Journal.
RUBIN: The idea being that companies would
have to pay 15% of their profits in taxes
in every country in which they operate, such
that the location of where those profits are
is less important.
OEI: The way the current global minimum tax
design is being talked about is that there's
a 15% global minimum, and by a series of rules,
if a country does not put their tax rate at
15%, there's a very complicated mechanism
by which other countries can top up and tax
the difference.
And so then the idea would be, well, the US
doesn't want some other country to tax our
multinationals on the difference.
So it's in our incentive to make our tax 15%.
SIERRA: Okay let’s break it down - Tax rates
vary by location, which is why corporations
will look around the globe and try to find
countries with lower tax rates.
Once they do, they will shift a headquarters,
a portion of their operations, or their intellectual
property to that location.
And of course, this is much easier for a tech
or pharmaceutical company than an old school
brick-and-mortar business.
I mean think about - at one point companies
were mostly creating physical goods, and it
was extremely difficult to move large machinery
and operations across oceans.
But, in this new era, countries with favorable
tax rates are places like Ireland, Switzerland,
Singapore, the Netherlands, Luxembourg, or
Hong Kong.
A global minimum tax would stop this from
occurring, establishing one universal floor
at 15%.
If one country does not adopt a 15% corporate
tax rate, but something lower like 5%, then
other countries where the company operates,
could charge the difference - meaning the
company would be paying the minimum no matter
where they went.
RUBIN: The idea is to minimize those gaps
to reduce significantly the benefits of the
profit shifting that companies can do.
SIERRA: Okay so I know it doesn’t always
work out exactly this way, but in theory can
you just tell me how companies are technically
supposed to be taxed?
RUBIN: Companies are taxed based on their
profits.
So, as opposed to you, you're taxed on your
income, you get some deductions, but we don't
think of individuals as profit making in the
same way.
For companies, they're taxed on their profits.
So, they take the revenue minus their expenses.
Those expenses can be wages, those expenses
can be office space, those expenses can be
the construction of new facilities, all those
things that companies do.
And they're taxed on the profit, the money
that they make in a given year.
The basic principle has been you're taxed
where value is created, where profit is happening.
That's not always a simple thing to translate
into reality, into actual dollars.
What's been driving a lot of the concern lately
is that was a relatively easy to definition
to think about 50 to 60 years ago, when you
could say, "Okay, well, the automobile factory
is in this particular place and this particular
country, therefore that's the country that
should get to tax that income that that factory
is producing."
But as the economy has become less tangible,
as the things that are generating profits
are not factories, they're patents, they're
trademarks, they're websites that aren't in
any particular place, figuring out where those
profits are has become much more difficult
for governments.
SIERRA: Is there a global IRS that collects
from companies that operate around the world?
OEI: There is no global IRS in the sense that
there isn't one central organization that's
going to sort of come knocking on the multinational
companies door if they don't pay the taxes.
Sometimes you'll hear people say that in recent
years, the OECD has acted as a de facto world
tax organization.
SIERRA: The OECD, or Organisation for Economic
Co-operation and Development, has steered
global tax talks.
And last October, nearly 140 countries signed
onto a tentative deal, but that doesn’t
mean it’s across the finish line.
For it to work, all signatories have to go
home and get it approved through their legislative
bodies as well.
Implementation is complicated and the details
are still being ironed out - what is the compatibility
with current domestic tax laws? and what needs
to change?
This question signals a bigger issue - there
are two political battles - one on the international
stage and one in each individual country.
OEI: The OECD has taken probably the most
active role in the international space.
It's making policy, setting norms and standards,
putting out models, and then countries adopt
that.
But there is no central global tax authority.
That's generally a matter of domestic law
and sovereignty of individual nation states.
SIERRA: Okay so in other words, new technology,
IPs, all that, have given companies more flexibility
on where they are based.
And as companies exercise this new flexibility,
there is no centralized oversight.
This makes it harder to tax corporations as
they shift profits around.
Let’s talk about why some countries are
offering extremely low tax rates in the first
place.
OEI: Tax is one of the metrics along which
countries compete.
And so what the global minimum taxes is trying
to solve is that race to the bottom.
And so the race to the bottom is countries
have an incentive to drive tax rates lower
and lower in order to attract taxpayers to
residence in their jurisdiction.
SIERRA: Interesting.
OEI: The details are mind bogglingly terrible,
but the bare bones idea is that.
SIERRA: Basically countries want big companies
to reside in their borders.
This isn’t just for bragging rights, but
also because it could provide jobs and promote
local economic growth.
So to attract a big company, a country will
offer a low corporate tax rate.
And another country might offer them an even
lower rate.
And another one… you see where I am going
with this - over time countries will go lower
and lower to attract big companies to their
shores, which creates that race to the bottom
and allows companies to pay less and less
taxes as they go.
And of course this is just one of many ways
for corporations to legally work the tax system.
There are other ways they do it too, let’s
look specifically at the US for a moment.
OEI: In reality, after the effect of tax loopholes,
or tax deductions, or tax incentives, corporations
aren't paying a huge amount of tax.
The corporate tax rate in the US is supposed
to be 21%.
What you see is that in actuality, a lot of
corporations are probably paying a lot less
than that.
And so then that feeds into the discourse
that they're not effectively paying a 21%
tax.
SIERRA: P.S.
You may have noticed that the global minimum
tax of 15% is actually lower than the US’s
current 21% tax rate.
But a reminder that 15% is a floor.
Plus, the 21% rate is often not fully paid,
and the effective rate - the rate companies
actually end up paying - is way lower.
We’ll get into exactly how corporations
finegale this in a minute.
But the key takeaway for now is that, in most
cases, a 15% floor would be higher than what
actually gets paid, and it would force the
US to tighten our tax laws, otherwise other
countries could claim the difference.
OEI: Some of that tax minimization is legal
under the tax law, and that's a whole different
conversation.
But after the application of what one might
colloquially call loopholes, the effective
rate might be in some circumstances reduced
to zero.
And that is certainly something we've seen
among some corporations in the US.
SIERRA: To give you some examples - a US company
might reinvest in growth and development,
this would lower their profit margin and they’d
have a lower tax liability.
Another thing they can do is add solar panels,
this would give them a tax credit.
These are just two tools to get tax breaks
in the US, among countless other tools that
companies use to lower their tax bill.
And it works.
Let’s look at Amazon.
This company has become an expert at working
the corporate tax system.
You might remember this, back in 2018, Amazon
made a whole bunch of headlines…
Fox Business: News out that Amazon is paying
zero in federal income taxes for the 2nd year
in a row.
Yahoo Finance: Zero, zero, zero dollars, zero
in taxes.
CNBC: That massive company paid no federal
income tax on more than 11 billion in profits
in 2018.
SIERRA: And in following years, Amazon continued
to pay far less than the 21% rate.
If the Global Minimum Tax became reality,
Amazon and other companies would not be able
to reduce their tax bill unchecked.
OEI: Yeah.
So, Amazon is a good example because that's
a big US multinational corporation.
And so, you'd look at that corporation and
you'd say, well, you are subject to a 21%
rate in the US, but then the question is,
so in the US, how much is Amazon paying?
And so the way ITEP, Institute for Taxation
and Economic Policy, right it’s a think
tank, calculated the effective tax rate for
2021 was 6.1%.
And looking back over years, 9.4% in 2020.
That is based on a certain calculation, but
the bottom line is, you're looking at a 21%
statutory rate.
And then you are trying to back out and say,
how much of this income do we estimate as
should be the taxable profit base, gee, it's
looking a lot less than 21%.
SIERRA: I was going to say, six, nine, those
aren't 21.
So, it's not even close.
OEI: Yeah.
SIERRA: For decades now, multinational companies
have been using all the tools we’ve talked
about to lower their taxes, while making record
profits.
In 2020, 55 of the largest corporations in
the US paid $0 in US federal corporate income
tax, including FedEx, Nike, and Salesforce.
And the kicker, that same year, together these
55 companies got $3.5 billion back from the
government through rebates.
But the biggest shock came from the Silicon
Six - Amazon, Facebook, Google’s parent
company Alphabet, Netflix, Apple and Microsoft
who reportedly have a $100 billion tax gap
that grew in the last decade.
Yet, these companies still benefit from the
services that tax dollars bring to the societies
they operate in, like the tax money used to
build schools, to pave roads, to provide healthcare,
and to pay for a defense budget.
The global minimum tax money might help us
pay for these exact needs or even allow governments
to lower taxes on the individual side or decrease
the US deficit.
At the end of the day it will be up to the
government.
But ultimately, the global minimum tax would
bring in, collectively, $150 billion in additional
tax revenue each year.
RUBIN: The corporate income tax is a significant
revenue source.
It brings in hundreds of billions of dollars
a year to the US government.
So, as a US taxpayer, or as a taxpayer of
any country, you're going to want to care
whether corporate income is taxed and how
it's taxed.
It's also not just important as a dollar amount
of revenue source, but because corporations
tend to be owned by higher income people,
the corporate income tax is one of the more
progressive sources of revenue that the government
has.
The idea is that you create a floor under
what companies pay and that provides money
to governments to pay for programs.
SIERRA: Does this apply to every company or
is it just the biggest ones?
RUBIN: I think it will be tech companies,
pharmaceutical companies, probably some consumer
product companies here and there, probably
some of the chip makers.
And I think probably less so retailers and
finance industry companies.
SIERRA: A lot of those new sectors.
RUBIN: Right.
SIERRA: And FYI, this only applies to corporations
making over 750 million Euros in annual revenue,
that's roughly over $800 million dollars.
OEI: I think the reason why people talk a
lot about tech is that often the customers,
the digital users are in different jurisdictions
than the plant.
And so, you know, the deal will be more salient
to those companies, but the terms of the deal
don't name specific sectors.
So it's literally by revenue.
It's just that we are pretty sure that the
tech and the pharma company, those big companies
will be hit by it.
SIERRA: So, what if a country decides to sit
out?
Won't that just attract multinational companies,
corporations to move there?
RUBIN: Right.
So, you need a critical mass of countries
in order to make this work.
But the way it works is that it's imposed
by the country where the company is headquartered.
So, if you're a US company, we will look at
how much profit you make in each country around
the world and will charge you up to 15% to
make sure that you're not putting profits
in any low tax country.
So, if the US does that for its companies
and other countries that are part of this
deal, France, the UK, Germany, Japan do the
same thing for companies that are headquartered
in those places, all of a sudden you've got
a very significant chunk of global multinational
income that's captured by this tax.
SIERRA: So who wants this?
Who's pushing hardest for it?
RUBIN: The Biden Administration is pushing
very hard for this.
And the Biden Administration wants to bring
everybody else along so that, as you were
talking about, there aren't necessarily opportunities
for companies to go elsewhere and have an
advantage if they're not a US company.
Just as a policy matter, you want to minimize
the benefits that a company could get if it
were to become a British company or an Australian
company or whatever.
RUBIN: And other countries want this too.
Other countries, like France and Germany,
there are lots of countries that are on board
for this.
OEI: The primary drivers of the whole thing
at the beginning were the OECD countries and
then the G20 came on board.
You know I think it's a complicated coalition
of stakeholders.
Certainly the wealthier global North countries
I think are pushing it.
So the EU is certainly there.
In the Biden administration, the US is certainly
there.
Although others have argued that the alignment
of interest is not completely perfect, right
because the US has the big multinationals.
And I think the US would like to be getting
more tax out of the multinationals, but we
wouldn't want someone else to be getting the
tax instead of us, right so there's a bit
of an interplay there.
I think people would argue that it is also
good for non-haveney less wealthy countries,
like lower income countries.
This idea that if you put a 15% minimum on
the table, then you're less likely to have
tax havens just basically eliminate the base.
So less wealthy countries that may need to
raise revenue may also benefit.
SIERRA: How do developing countries feel about
a global minimum tax?
OEI: First of all, it's a very heterogeneous
group.
And so you're talking from the BRICS, Brazil,
Russia, India, China, to smaller developing
countries, lower income countries.
There's a whole variety of actors here.
I think views are mixed.
Many have signed on.
It's not entirely clear what's driving it.
My own research sort of suggests that there
may be a wanting to comply in order to avoid
being on some list of naughty actors, right…
SIERRA: Interesting.
Yeah.
OEI: …that EU had put together right, but
it's very hard to know.
Maybe the way to talk about it is I think
there is some anxiety about not getting an
adequate cut of the deal.
So, the worry is, are we going to be forced
to abandon some of our tax incentive regimes?
That's a general tension with these rules.
Are we specifying what the minimum tax is,
or are we actively telling countries how they
can and cannot design their tax systems?
SIERRA: Yeah.
OEI: And there's some debate over how far
it goes and how far it should.
SIERRA: So, I guess my question is where are
we at with all this?
What's the current status of the global minimum
tax?
RUBIN: It's messy right now.
SIERRA: Sounds pretty messy.
RUBIN: It's pretty messy.
So, let's take it in two pieces.
Abroad, countries are trying to start to go
ahead to put their pieces in place.
France is leading the EU at the moment and
is trying to push this ahead to get European
countries to agree on exactly how the system
will work and to implement it in the next
year or so.
SIERRA: Since we recorded our interviews,
Poland blocked a proposal that outlined how
to implement the global minimum tax across
the EU, this is a major setback.
But Europe is not the only place where progress
is stalled.
RUBIN: In the US, it’s stalled in Congress
as part of the Build Back Better initiative.
There's actually not a ton of controversy
among Democrats in Congress.
Republicans don't like it, but Democrats are
basically fine with this piece of the legislation.
It's the other parts of the bill that have
caused problems.
So, if some reconciliation legislation, some
fiscal package moves in Congress, I would
expect this to be part of it on the democratic
side.
So, all of that, like the US minimum tax effort,
the international minimum tax effort, the
idea is that everything sort of marches forward
together in coordination and you all know
better than me…
SIERRA: How's that going?
RUBIN: The entire world marching forward together
in coordination doesn't always work very well.
And so that, I think is, I'm not saying it
won't happen.
I'm just saying it has been a long process
and will continue to be a long process with
this sort of dance of US legislators looking
around the world and saying, "Are you guys
really going to do this?"
And then the European legislators looking
at Congress and saying, "Are you guys really
going to do this?"
Right?
So, I think if everyone, you know, holds hands
and leaps, then it works.
SIERRA: I was going to say, it's like getting
dared to jump into a pool or something.
RUBIN: Yeah.
SIERRA: Yeah.
RUBIN: But if it starts being very clear that
it falls apart … So if for example, if we
get to January 2023 and at least one chamber
of Congress is in Republican hands and this
hasn't moved through Congress, European countries
are going to be very skeptical about the Biden
Administration's ability to deliver on this.
SIERRA: Okay.
RUBIN: Yeah.
So, it is you can't put that in the podcast.
SIERRA: Oh, I can't put your shrug?
RUBIN: You can't put my crazy shrug in my
podcast.
But I've been covering several years and I've
just ...
SIERRA: Crazy shrug.
RUBIN: Crazy shrug.
Yeah.
SIERRA: There is an uphill battle ahead, and
what is at stake goes far beyond our government’s
revenue stream.
CODEPINK: Hey-He-Ho-Ho tax evaders have got
to go!
Hey-He-Ho-Ho tax evaders have got to go!
SIERRA: So closing out, we live in an atmosphere
of frustration with financial inequality and
a lot of criticism of unfair advantages for
corporations, and of course, the super wealthy,
a lot of people feel like it's a rigged game.
Do you think that if this worked out and companies
were paying taxes more equally, and governments
were gaining more revenue, that it might help
repair some of the trust that's been lost
between citizens and corporations?
OEI: Yeah.
That's certainly the hope, I think the hope
is if you're seeing your biggest companies
pay a larger share of their profits in taxes,
and you're less hearing about them hiding
profits offshore, or putting them in low tax
jurisdictions instead of bringing them home,
that contributes to a feeling of democratic
quality in the country.
I think that's certainly the hope.
Of course, now as a tax person, I have to
say, well, you have to worry about things
like incidents, does the corporation pass
on the tax burden to shareholders or to workers?
I don't know.
Right.
But certainly in terms of morale building,
I think a non-trivial part of the exercise
of taxing is building citizenship.
So this idea that wealthy companies and wealthy
individuals, right are paying a fair share
I think certainly can't hurt.
SIERRA: For resources used in this episode
and more information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes.
Have a question or some feedback?
Just feel like saying hi?
Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And if you are a fan, we’d love it if you
could leave us a review.
Ideally a good one, the more stars the better.
It really does help us get noticed and we
really do appreciate it.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The show is produced by Asher Ross and me,
Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria.
Rafaela Siewert is our associate podcast producer.
Our intern this semester is Roshni Rangwani.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Extra help for this episode was provided by
James McBride and Kali Robinson.
Original music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Special thanks go to Richard Haass, Jeff Reinke
and our co-creator Jeremy Sherlick.
For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off.
See you soon!